[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of beginner breakdown as
always my name is Alex mullering and I'm
excited to be working with you on our
lecture today
yeah come on in welcome in
um so today we're going to be talking
about uh simplification and
complications uh and the basic idea of
what that means is just how tricky any
given position is Right
often to simplify a position means we're
going to be trading a lot of pieces or
removing a lot of tactical threats just
making it simpler to understand a lot of
end games you could think of as being a
little simpler
versus a complicated position is one
where a lot of pieces are threatened and
there's a lot of pieces are still on the
board in general maybe threats on both
Kings it's back and forth It's unclear
maybe there's an imbalance
and it's sometimes hard to know when to
do one or the other and I often see
beginners kind of confuse when to do
what so we're going to go through a few
different examples and actually not a
lot but mostly just some games that I
think are kind of instructive in this
matter
and I'm going to use two examples that
I've used in previous lectures this
first one is really really basic
and the question is it's black to move
and just kind of looking at this
position
what might be the best idea for black
here so uh as always if you are watching
this live feel free to put your comments
in the chat if you're here in the
audience feel free to say something if
you have an idea and if you're watching
this later on YouTube always feel free
to pause the video to try and find the
best move if that's something you're
interested in so anyone have any idea
what we should be doing here as black
what kind of things come to mind
foreign
either in person or in the chat what you
would play you can always kind of just
notice stuff about the position you
think is relevant
that should factor into our decision
making
please
Bishop to where I'm sorry
uh Bishop so okay so Bishop takes so
what's why do you want to take the
Knight
so that's a really good observation so
uh someone in the chat had an idea I
think of playing Knight C4 which looks
like a really good move trapping The
Rook but unfortunately you've picked up
that we actually don't have time to do
that because white has this forcing
check Knight to C5
so if we tried something like Knight C4
which normally would be good to punish
this piece now we're actually in trouble
because the Rook is going to escape and
we're going to lose material
so we can't just do something slow we
have to do something to answer this
threat and Bishop takes is a very nice
way to you know stop that are there any
other reasons we might want to play
Bishop takes or maybe as opposed to
taking with the Knight
sure and that's fair do you think
there's one of those is better than the
other
I mean Bishop takes comes with check so
I agree I think Bishop takes is probably
I think they're both about the same but
Bishops takes just practically speaking
I like more because like you said it
comes with checks so this is what we
call a forcing move
um I've done electron forcing moves
before I'll do one again at some point
I'm sure but it's always important to
recognize
um when you can play a move that limits
what your opponent can do in this case
because it's a check whatever move they
play it has to be in response to the
check so you either have to remove this
piece or block or move the king out of
the way
you are forcing your opponent into a
limited scenario which is useful for
calculation it's easier to calculate
when they only can do two or three
things than when they can do nine or ten
um so yeah I like taking here first okay
let's say they just take back
what might we do now
oh yes
um and I see someone in the chat uh
a few people in the chat with some fun
names
um are suggesting that we just trade off
these pieces um kind of just continue to
trade uh on on D3
until really everything is stopped and I
agree
um and for the same reason as before
where we wanted to take with the bishop
we still want to do a forcing move so I
want to play Rook takes D3
um Knight takes D3 again is probably
still fine but if we take with the Rook
now we're we are forcing our opponent to
respond because even though it's not a
check
the only way to not trade is to move
this Rook out of the way which would
just give us this one for free so white
doesn't have time to do anything other
than allow us to continue the trade and
for the same reason I will trade again
this time they can avoid a trade they
could move their Rook somewhere but
there's not really a lot of useful
places to do so and okay if they decide
to avoid this there's not really much I
could do even if I take with the Knight
um but if they do decide to trade down
either way I will be up in this end game
notice how white has four pawns and I
have six
and none of them are passed on either
side there's maybe a few different
backwards ideas but
with best play All Things Considered
black should be able to find a way to
win this game
um whether by using the pawn majority on
this side so try and break through and
force the king to play defense and then
maybe cleaning up these ones with our
King and winning on the queen side or
maybe the opposite maybe we just use
this Pawn majority to break through with
our King as well and find a win there
but either way black should be doing
quite well and it's important to see
that even without looking at this threat
even if you can't find the Knight to C5
is a really big threat we have to worry
about
we can still find this move
taking on D3 just by looking at the
material count and saying okay we have
both sides have two Rooks both sides
have a bishop and a knight
but we have a bunch more pawns and
there's no other positional reason why
we wouldn't be able to win with these
extra pawns so one reason to simplify to
trade a bunch of pieces is when you're
up material that's probably the most
common reason to simplify is because
it's a lot easier to win When there's
less on the board and you have an
advantage
to kind of illustrate that a little
farther I want to take a look at this
position which happened in a grand
master game between Nigel short and Ivan
chaparnov this happened in 2008 and I
believe in this position I think it was
Ivan's turn
and it was and so here quickly looking
at the position with black to move
we have both sides have a pawn both
sides have a bishop but white is up the
exchange white has this extra Rook for
the Knight and the question is will
white be able to convert this Victory is
this work for a night enough of an
advantage that white can win
or will black be able to hold a draw
well black took a look and realized uh
let's see black took a look and realized
that
there is a fork opportunity if I play
Knight to F6 check then after Bishop
takes Mike the bishop can't take because
of the PIN
so after we take with our Bishop their
King can take and their King will be
closer to our pawn and it will be a lot
harder for us to win The Rook versus
Bishop especially if they can get our
Pawn somehow it's just a little
uncomfortable and so I haven't decided
to play Knight to F6 Trek forking the
king and the pawn trying to force a draw
in a worse material position
and in this position it's actually
really critical already what white does
because this is the difference if we
just play something like moving our King
to get out of check then black will
happily eat this pawn and almost surely
we will get a draw now it's actually
probably white who's playing for the
draw because at least black has an extra
Pawn they might try and promote somehow
so we have to take
King takes
again the bishop was pinned so you
cannot take with the bishop
and now
this is probably the most critical point
in this example it's white to move
and we have to ask ourselves
uh how can we win this game
the quest and it kind of comes down to
this idea of simplification but we have
to be very precise in how we do it so if
you want to take a look at this position
for a minute and try and find the best
move for white it is not as easy as it
looks you have to play precisely but see
if you can figure out what we ought to
do here in order to win this game
foreign
but then because
the king can't take because then they
would lose the bishop okay so that's
true so if King takes then we take the
bishop and
um our Rook versus the pawn without it
being this far Advanced will be an easy
win but go ahead
oh I see well so I do think I actually
think you're right
um on your initial Instinct where if
they take I do think us getting this
bishop is going to be more than enough
to win they can try and block off the
king but when you have something like a
king and a rook versus a king and a pawn
as long as the pawn isn't too far
Advanced like it's just on its own
um like if there's another Pawn it's a
different story but on its own there's
actually a pretty simple way to
cause a problem because the only way for
black to win here is for them to get
their Pawn all the way down to the end
of the board and promote
and in order to do that they actually
need to guard it the whole time with
their King because if at any point their
King gets too far away our Rook can
slide like wherever it needs to all the
way across the board and hit the pawn
so all we have to do is stop the king
from being anywhere near the pond and
um I don't know let's say black plays
some move
we can just already start working to
find some way to separate the king from
the pawn If This Were Me
I might play
let's see a few different options here
hello Pumpkin the cat in the chat we are
glad to have you
I'm considering just rookie four
if the king gets too far away then
maybe I can invade with my king quickly
if the king stays behind
then I'm always really happy if the king
is here because now my Rook can stay
here forever and the king is never going
to be able to get past this row so I can
just kind of very calmly
move my King around
I do need to keep the king from you know
invading
but eventually I will be able to find
some way to do this I may have just
messed up slightly because I'm giving my
opponent an opportunity to step in here
um
maybe even if I just go all the way over
here because you can't really push this
Pawn your king won't be able to defend
it anymore
so I don't really know what black does
maybe try and go this way to get around
but at some point you're just going to
run out of moves
um so even with my very imprecise play
in an end game
this is not the easiest thing to do now
surely black could try and win but
um with solid play and enough time on
your clock white should be able to win
if we go for this
and black decides to take that this
would be a very risky decision for black
to make
um
it would actually be a lot safer for
black to retreat so if we take this
Knight
takes and push G5 Black's probably just
going to retreat their King to F7
now there is a really critical idea here
though
um and I want to see if we can figure
out why so we're we're very close to the
right idea but we have to get a few more
pieces in play
and maybe to help think about this right
with our question of simplification
if we are in some position where we can
simplify and just know we're going to
win we should probably do it
so my question to you is can we just
take this bishop right now
if we play Rook takes Bishop the King
has to take
will we be able to win this position
so a few different thoughts on the chat
so
it looks better
uh pumpkin the cat so pumpkin the cat's
first suggestion in the chat was G5 and
then after the king moves to then take
the bishop but there's actually a very
critical difference only one of these
wins so uh do you think we should take
the bishop first or do you think we
should push the pawn first and then take
the bishop which one of these is going
to lead to a win
I take the bishop right away okay what's
your reasoning
um so we have Tempo in a way we we're
going to actually be in opposition if we
want it right we can put our King in
opposition which is going to put black
in a bit of an awkward position
however
this is actually sadly the wrong answer
in this case for one very specific
reason
even though we get opposition black can
actually take opposition back
by pushing this Pawn
and even though there's no way for them
to defend it
when we take
they have opposition still which means
our King cannot Advance forward to
promote the pawn
so we can move to the side and they will
always come back and stop us
but at some point we will either have to
move our King backwards or move our Pawn
forwards and if any one of you have
studied King and Pawn in games we know
this is a draw because black will just
forever keep white from getting in front
and the critical idea to know in this
type of position is you always want to
meet a king stepping forward next to
their Pawn with opposition so black can
just simply move back in this position
and if white steps forward it's
opposition
we can call check if we want
if we don't we'll just reset the
position black steps in front of the
pawn and now whatever white does it's
over because we can either play any king
move that undefends the pawn and black
will take it for a draw or we can play
the only move that defends it which is
right here on G6 and now the King has no
legal moves we are cutting off every
possible Square
so remarkably because of this King and
pawn end game
let's go all the way back
we actually cannot take the bishop here
because black can make a very strategic
sacrifice in order to maintain
opposition and even though we have the
tempo at first they win it back and we
are in trouble so actually
um rigged yes so actually pushing Pawn
to G5 uh pumpkin the cat's first
suggested in the chat here is the
correct move because we take away their
option to have this extra waiting move
now after they move their King and we
take the bishop
now when we take opposition
they have no way to escape it they have
to concede space
so wherever they go
let's say this way we can slowly start
to work our way in we don't have to take
opposition here because our Pawn is
cutting off this Square so we can
actually go to D6 because they can't
move forward and wherever they go we're
just going to slowly follow in and take
the pawn
so however they want to play it
eventually we get this Pawn
and uh still not a trivial end game you
have to have studied this or spend some
time to figure it out but you can win
this uh with precise play and I believe
if I'm remembering my calculations
correctly
I want to say King H6
push you can goes back
now maybe that is incorrect
King H6
if King h8
Ah that's right because then when we
push
we take away this square and they have
to run this way
so instead after King H6 it says they're
supposed to go this way but now we can
just play King H7 and create the red
carpet for our Pawn so this is maybe a
reminder for me to brush up on my king
and pawning games but
that is always something important to
know in simplification is especially
with end games if you can figure out
where a precise win is or if you've seen
it in a book and you know oh if I get to
this position it's a win if you can find
a way to force that as in this case
where they did
um
white knew that even though he has extra
material he can guarantee a win instead
of having to face a long drawn out game
against this bishop that might cause him
some problems in the long run if he lets
it Escape
so one point on the board force
simplification is when you're up in
material
a second one is if you're in an end game
where simplifying down to something
simple even if it's of equal material
like King and pawn versus King Pawn
if it's a winning position for you
usually because your king is more active
or because you have opposition
then simplifying is going to work out in
your favor there as well
but now I want to talk about a really
interesting game that talks about when
not to simplify
uh this is a game this was actually a
really famous game it was the 10th and
final game of the 1965 candidates
quarterfinals
um this was the match between Paul kariz
as the white here and Boris spasky he
had black and Carries was a point down
so the player with white was one point
down in this match and the way a chess
tournament works is if you win a game
you get a point if you lose a game you
get zero points and if you draw you get
half a point
Kerry's being a point down against
spaski meant that if he wanted to have
any chance in this tournament he needed
to win the game because if he wins he
gets a point spaski stays with zero and
they're even now
so cares is playing for a win if Boris
spass you with the black pieces gets a
draw
then he's going to win the whole match
because he's up a point both of them get
a half he's he retains his lead of a
point
so these are the stakes for this
tournament
um and something really interesting
happens
D4 Knight to F6 C4 and here we would
expect some very classical chess spassky
a very solid very strong I mean also
very sharp player but we would expect
him just hoping for a draw you know he
doesn't need to fight for a win he's
going to play D5 or maybe like E6 to
play D5 get into some very classical
positions his pawns are going to be in
the center nothing unusual and the the
onus is on Kara's to prove that he can
find a win with the white pieces
spassky instead plays the move Pawn to
G6 which to just like a beginner these
are just kind of normal positions but
this is a really interesting move
because instead of playing kind of
principled Chess right when we're ever
looking at the opening there's really
three main principles I always devise
one of them is you control the center so
finding moves that control the center of
the board second one is opening up
opportunities to develop your pieces so
especially your Knights and your Bishops
um is really important
and third you want to get your king to
safety if you leave your king out in the
open too long then it can be attacked or
yeah cause you issues so usually you'll
castle some positions you can delay that
a little bit but whatever you do you
want your king safe
so instead of following kind of the
principled response of taking the center
in some way spassky just completely
concedes it he plays a move G6 he's
going to play Bishop to G7
and just give carers the full Center
which is what happens Knight C3 Bishop
G7 E4 D6 F4
Paul Caris takes full advantage of the
fact that
um spassky is giving him this he puts
all four of these Pawns in the center if
you look at how much space they're
controlling it's quite uh terrifying if
you're on the black side of this
especially if you're not familiar with
this opening this is not something you
want to face unprepared this kind of
four pawns attack in the king's Indian
and yet
spassky is going for this um idea
because of a really interesting I guess
this is almost a psychological principle
where
any experienced chess player will kind
of know that if you were playing a game
of chess for a draw like if you're
hoping whether it's from the start of a
game or in the middle of a game you
realize okay maybe I can't win this let
me just play for a draw you're already
increasing your chances of losing
because at the very least you don't
think a win is Within Reach
if spaski had started this game playing
classical chess he might have gone on to
win he might have gone on to lose he
might have gone underdraw but he's
already playing for a draw and his
opponent is playing for a win his
opponent is going to be looking for
every possible opportunity to push
spassky to make tough choices
and spaski decides I'm not going to let
my opponent make me play that game we're
both gonna play it so he enters some
complications when most people would say
maybe he shouldn't
okay so F4 we need to do something we
cannot let white just continue to
dominate the center here
so spaski does Strike Back with C5 a
very kind of strong classical move uh
attacking the center trying to tear
apart this big wall of Pawns and opening
up space as well to get the knight in
the game get the queen on this diagonal
so we'll see what happens from there D5
continuing to hold on to the space
[ __ ] castles
Knight to F3 developing a knight
controlling E5 again with all of this
Pawn advantage in the center carriers
would love to just push forward trade
break open uh everything in the center
and have a really nice advantage
spassy can't let that stay for too long
so he plays E6 he needs to put some
challenge here to White's control
Bishop E2 developing preparing to Castle
Pawn takes D5 Pawn takes D5
and here again we reach a really
interesting position so white does still
have these three pawns we've traded off
one of them for one of ours
um
but we at least are controlling a little
bit of space here maybe it's harder now
for white to push forward perhaps ideas
like Rook E8 might come
um maybe this bishop will come to G4
there's lots of different ways that you
could approach this position
and yet spaski instead of trying to play
very simple solid moves
continues to add complications
in this position he plays the move Pawn
to B5
which is looking to press forward on the
queen side gain space and keep the
initiative right not give his opponent
the chance to strike he's taking it for
himself
um
in the game
E5 was played
but it should be noted that even though
this Pawn is not defended right it's
attacked by these two pieces not
defended there are some sort of tactical
defenses but
even if you employ those spassky is
giving up a pawn so for instance we
could see something like Bishop takes
Pawn
and now this really nice trick Knight
takes E4 so winning the pawn keeping
them equal but now it looks like we're
sacrificing this Knight
what's the idea well if Knight takes
then Queen to A5 check picking up the
bishop
um
you can't just drop the Knight back
because we have Bishop takes so that
won't help anything
so instead what would probably happen
would be king to F2 Queen takes B5 but
now white still is going to get this
extra Pawn with Knight takes D6
attacking the queen creating a very very
powerful past Pawn although it is
isolated so it doesn't have enough a
pawn to support it or keep it safe so it
is going to be a little harder to defend
but it's you know not too far from enemy
territory
so there are a lot of dangers in this
position and it's kind of remarkable
that spassky was willing to go into this
imbalanced game
um knowing all he needed was a draw this
is totally fine for black but it is a
very risky way to play we are down a
pawn for some initiative
um
okay
let's get back to our actual game
because this is not what carries went
for after B5 carries went for probably a
better move
um of E5
because Karis even though you know maybe
he wins a pawn he still doesn't really
want to simplify by trading off his
pieces he wants to keep a lot of pieces
on the board to continue to pressure and
what he's been building towards with F4
and Knight F3 all of these moves are
trying to break through the center and
just completely dominate
okay well D takes E5 is basically forced
Pawn takes and Knight to G4 moving the
Knight to safety attacking the pawn
creating a discovered attack
um and this is kind of the whole style
of this type of opening approach so
again we said in the very beginning
taking the center with your pawns is a
more classical Style
this is usually called like a hyper
modern approach where you give your
opponent the center at first with the
idea that you're going to strike back if
you just give them the center and then
let them keep it and don't do anything
to fight against it you're gonna just
get blown off the board every time
but it is okay to give them the center
if you're going to fight back for it and
that's what we see spassky doing here
um okay so this Pawn is threatened twice
defended once
so Karis plays Bishop F4 adding an extra
Defender
Knight to D7 uh developing with another
attack
and E6
carries again creating very complex
positions notice that he has not taken
the time to Castle his King
um
instead he is continuing to maintain
pressure he's trying to now take space
more in the center and blow open Black's
King side for attacking chances right
remember Carrie is here with the white
pieces needs to win this game he can't
afford a draw so he's playing all these
risky moves what's amazing is that
spassky's going there right with him
um and in this position
there is kind of a safer way to play
um perhaps the safest solid way to play
would be something like Knight to E5
here opening up attack with the bishop
and then we might see something like
Knight takes Knight takes uh Bishop
takes B5 Pawn takes E6 maybe White
Castles and we have some imbalances they
have to do something about this attack
so castles and this is a more balanced
game right both sides are still fighting
but some pieces have been exchanged and
if you're the player who all you need is
a draw this is going to be in your favor
but again spaski opts to make it a
little more complicated he takes with a
pawn
and this is doing a few things
one it's obviously threatening to
continue to win back in the center it is
exposing the king slightly to a
potential future attack it's also
opening up this discovery on the bishop
but this is something that carries had
seen and planned for and Carries allows
him to take the bishop Pawn takes on E6
because after Rook takes F4 there is
this nice idea
um
I'll actually let you guys take a second
with this one
white just decided to sacrifice this
piece what is the reason why it is not
completely lost how can white pick
something back up what threat can they
make that's a really nice move in this
position
uh take oh with the uh the pawn or the
probably the pawn because Bishop depends
yeah taking the Knight is interesting
um
if you take the Knight
the only problem I have with it is I do
defend the square twice and so I win
this bishop but if you take my knight
we're even but then I'm gonna get this
pawn and not only do I get it but I'm
also sort of Defending my own and maybe
you can trade again and force me to win
it but carries wants to he doesn't want
stuff to get traded right he wants more
material on the board to make it more of
a threat so either he's going to be
losing a little bit of material from a
pawn or he'll be able to keep it at the
cost of getting a bunch of stuff off the
board so it's not a bad idea but it's
for like
um it's definitely a good move
but it's not really in the style carries
needs to push for a win
a Wagoner don't know how to say your
name in the chat 88
um you have a really nice idea with
actually Queen to D5
this is the move played in the game
picking up on the facts if you think
back to our lesson on in unpredicted
pieces
this Rook on A8 is not safe and Black's
King is somewhat exposed because now the
threat is both I'm going to take this
but also I still have this threat of
taking or pushing with check
so we're going to win back more than
that Bishop we're going to win back
probably a rook
so let's go back
so again all of this comes about because
sebasket decides to play this
double-edged game with f take C6
and pawn takes back
and now
if you go for this Rook F4 line then
there's all this danger with uh Queen D5
and you're probably in a lot of trouble
um a safer move here is something like
Knight B6 again hoping to trade the
Queens defending this piece opening up
an attack here and just trying to
simplify the position right that should
it seems like that should be spasticy's
whole goal so something like Queen takes
or takes maybe bishop takes that pawn we
take on E6
and you know white still has a very
slight Edge from the first move you know
they have some Tempo maybe a little bit
of spatial control but it's a little
better
but this is not one carries once he
doesn't want a kind of very close game
with slight positional struggles because
that's more likely to end in a draw
and again spaski doesn't go for this
option he plays Rook takes F4
he allows Queen to D5
and in this position instead of trying
any move to save his Rook he doesn't
play the very simple move to restore
material just give back this bishop you
know Bishop B7
Queen takes Knight B6 and you solve both
problems he's not playing this simple
style of chess
instead in this position spassky plays
King h8
which is
an inspired move
because spaski is basically fully
committing to
the whole game so far you've seen he's
been willing to create complications
um
but in this case he's saying yeah not
only am I willing to do that I'm willing
to let it be so unbalanced that I'm
going to go down this exchange you can
have my Rook I'm just going to keep a
lot of pressure and Tempo and activity
and that's what happens Queen takes A8
Knight B6 gaining Time by attacking the
queen
and now carries is left with two moves
and this is where it gets really
interesting as well because now we kind
of see roles reverse whereas spassky the
player who just needs a draw is
theoretically should be trying to
simplify at every turn and has
consistently been complicating things
now we see
um spaski give it over to carries and
Carries has really two options here his
Queen is attacked and if you look where
can it go okay it can't go here because
of the Rook can't go here because of the
Knight and the Queen
I guess it could go to C6 although I'd
be a little hesitant
to put it there
um the main moves would be either Queen
takes A7 getting this Pawn or queen to
B8 uh not taking the pawn But continuing
to put pressure on the position
attacking The Rook keeping uh this
bishop on C8 pinned and adding some
complications
and unlike spassky who has shown a
willingness to engage in these
complications
Queen takes A7 simply winning some
material here
um carries is the one picking the safer
options he's simplifying when maybe he
shouldn't be
had he played Queen B8 pinning the
pieces it's still really complex right
we might see some super crazy moves like
um Knight E3 preventing light from
castling
and then the computer even gives this
awesome move Rook to D1 sacking The Rook
back attacking the queen
you don't take it Queen E7 Rook D2 and
there's just some really wild positions
where it's totally anyone's game but
it's super imbalanced but this is not
what carries us after he plays Queen A7
simplifying slightly
okay well he does win this Pawn
um but he does allow Bishop takes E6
which you know uh he's trying to make it
safer for him he wants the castle which
he does but he's giving up this kind of
linchpin this pressure in the position
this past Pawn in White's court so now
it's a little easier first basket to
calculate maybe not the wisest decision
okay uh black to move he plays Knight E3
attacking White's Rook
and um
you know white has completed development
but now that spaski's pieces like if we
look at all of them there's so much
activity right
um this Knight especially this Rook on
F4 the bishop is wide open
um
he decides
well he puts carries in this position
again to decide do do I want to maintain
this material advantage right I have
this Rook he could off opt to you know
play some other move uh give it back try
and win back some time you know
something like Rook D1
to win back some time on the queen
something like this or even maybe bishop
takes B5 would be better
Knight takes Rook takes
something like Rook F7 and black has
some compensation attacking the queen
getting a lot of time
but is down a pawn this is a real fight
instead of continuing to make it more
complex and trying to really push
Kara's plays this is really the first
mistake of the game he plays Rook to F2
trying to hold on to this material
uh
which in this case is actually the
simpler option he sees I have an
advantage and I'm trying to keep it
simple rather than give it back
the cost of this is quite High though
because if we actually take a look at
the pieces here you'll notice that
blacks pieces are quite strong very
active placed on good squares
controlling key areas in the opponent's
territory
um
white pieces are pretty uncoordinated
right this queen is just kind of
disconnected from everything going on
this Rook is still sitting on the edge
not doing anything so now that this Rook
isn't even connected anymore like
there's no ideas of doubling up because
of the night it's just kind of unclear
what white is actually trying to do
and this is really going to benefit
spask in the long run
spasky plays B4 attacking the Knight
gaining space and time right doesn't
want to give white a chance to pull
everything together because now that he
does have a material disadvantage he
needs to make sure all of his pieces and
pawns are doing everything they can he's
not giving his opponent free moves to
consolidate
Knight to B5
keeping that I active But continuing to
make this big disconnect right all of
these pieces aren't interacting with
each other there's no Harmony in light's
position
work back to F7
attacking and queen A5
and here we see another interesting move
we see Queen to B8
spasky is not interested in trying to
gain material in this position but he is
instead looking to directly start an
attack against White's King
rookie one
Bishop D5 trying to release one of the
Defenders from here
Bishop F1 and spaski could have
continued with Knight G4 continuing to
attack H2 put more pressure he decides
actually after this move though but he
wants to kind of hurt white on these
light squares so he plays Knight takes
F1 Rook takes
and Knight C4 stepping in where the
bishop used to be covering attacking the
queen attacking this Pawn really
threatening some critical squares
okay Queen A6 and this queen is just
really bouncing back around
unfortunately now that this Knight has
moved to B5 the queen has to stay and
kind of guard it
um
and yeah none of this is pretty Rook to
F6 the spatsky slowly improving his
pieces and just continuing to force the
queen to go to uncomfortable positions
that takes B2 and here just under all of
this pressure I believe in the game
carries also was in a big time pressure
as well but under all the psychological
pressure of just this kind of continual
grinding position that spassky is
exerting
um in addition to the probably
unexpected element of psychological
warfare where you know spassky is
probably going into this game carries
expected a long drawn out positional
battle where he was going to be trying
to make things happen and spaski instead
of saying no I'm gonna turn up the heat
right here with you I'm going to make it
complicated all of this together is yeah
just too much and he plays Queen to C2
which actually just loses a piece
because even though it looks like you
can take this Knight and it's just a
trade really this doesn't work because
after Queen takes B5 if you take on V2
then black has a winning move in this
position
if you want to try and take a second to
find it what is Black's best move here
to just absolutely end the game
yeah
foreign
that's it yeah uh Rook F3
opening up this discovered attack
against the queen winning this night
um
black still has this beautiful Bishop
pair against this Rook black has two
pawns against one one of these is passed
um this is the game is just over there's
really nothing left to do here
um there is also this double attack
against this Rook like yeah white is
practically practically just lost
um so instead white realizes that you
can't take there and plays rookie seven
trying to make it more complicated
but Knight to D3
Queen E2 and just kind of a few more
moves to show how the game ends C4
slowly pushing forward taking space
preparing to Queen there's really
nothing to be done
check rook f8 and now that spasky's
ahead in material right he's made his
tactical threats and complications well
worth it by winning that night now he's
more than happy to simplify so this is a
really important shift that some people
have trouble making
when you are attacking generally you
don't want to simplify
because you want to have as many pieces
on the board to pressure your opponent
as possible when you're defending you
would love to take those pieces off
spassky has been attacking for most of
this game but now that he is in a
position where he's won back the
material he doesn't feel the need to
press in this particular way because now
if he can simplify he's just going to be
winning it's not even he's playing for a
draw anymore he's actually trying to win
now he decides this is fine and there's
not really much better for carers to do
again he's fairly low on time so he
trades
Knight to G5 trying to make some final
tricks happen with the Rook perhaps or
the Knight but unfortunately all of
these squares are covered
in a few more moves First bishop C5 with
a check forcing the king away
Queen to D7 just covering all of these
weaknesses with the Bishops and the
Queen
there is just nothing
for white to do
Queen D2
Queen E7 Knight F3
and queen E3 and in this position
carries runs out of time once again we
see spassky willing to trade Queens this
would be an excellent trade for him
again not to try and make this a a draw
not out of fear of his opponent you know
having some trick but because now he's
ahead and now if he trades everything
down he simplifies this position he will
have a very comfortable easy advantage
that he can go on to win
so that's I think this game is actually
more of a lesson about when not to
simplify uh you don't want to simplify
out of fear
whether your word your opponent is
better rated than you or
um maybe just has more experience or
you're in a position you're not really
comfortable in if you are trying to
simplify in order to you know make it
easier on yourself maybe it works for
that one game
I think this is a good Testament to even
examples where that's not the case but
also
um I think this was Bobby Fischer who
said this was he said like I don't try
and think about this psychologically I
just play good moves I think that's a
really good thing to think about right
look for the best moves in any given
position
um okay I want to show in the last kind
of 15 minutes I have a game that doesn't
really follow all of these ideas and
might give some uh Insight uh this is a
game that I actually played uh this
weekend
against
um someone here at the chess club and I
think there's some interesting insights
to be gleaned along the lines of
simplification where some players did
good things some players did bad things
we kind of both did each so I want to
walk through it important to note is my
opponent is rated 813 and I am rated
1459 so I have a significant rating
advantage and that was sort of in my
head that something that I don't like to
think about usually like I find that I
play worse when I know my opponent's
rating because I kind of I'm already
expecting what kind of game I'm getting
into instead of just trying to play the
best moves
um
so yeah I'm gonna cut NN Anonymous did
have a lot of games against morphe
Anonymous has probably played every
Grand Master it's pretty awesome
um but okay let's get into the game so
my opponent starts D4 Knight F6 uh
Knight C3 and already this is a bit of
an interesting move
um unlike in the spaski game where C4
was played and then G6 here Knight C3 is
sort of against the idea of this D4 move
um now white can play D5 or sorry black
can play D5 and there is no ability to
pressure that pawn with C4
um
however I have Simone like my own
opening knowledge is much more firmly
rooted in these kind of kidneys Indian
ideas so I just stuck with what I knew
and now E4 Knight defending and we've
transposed into a pierce defense as if
White had just played E4 and move one
um this is also something I'm
comfortable with but the position has
changed so the opening already some kind
of interesting move orders happening
Knight to F3 Bishop G7 and G3 another
sort of interesting move usually after
kind of Knight F3 my opponent playing
very classical in this peered system you
would see a move like Bishop E2 or maybe
bishop C4 and castles
um
in the G3 lines often this Knight might
come to E2 and the bishop goes to G4 but
this is what we have in this game
G3 castles Bishop G2 and now I play a
move that is I think slightly dubious
and along the lines that we talked about
this is not like a bad move but it looks
very natural I played Bishop to G4
pinning this Knight
but looking at it I have some
hesitations the first is I have been
burned in the past by not paying close
enough attention to my opponents fan
kettled Bishops and noticing now that
whenever my Bishop moves I am
undefending the pawn on B7 perhaps there
are some tactical tricks now not in this
position but like if my opponent
complicates things and I'm not paying
attention maybe there's some ways to get
some nice discovered attacks I have to
be careful of that possibility
additionally really my my biggest
critique with this move is that I played
it before I had fully committed to uh
taking this night
had I not wanted to take the night
probably I if I'm developing this bishop
I should just play Bishop D7
but once I play here my opponent can
make me a little uncomfortable with the
move H3
because now I have to really make a
decision am I going to retreat and sort
of waste a move
or am I going to risk getting into an
uncomfortable situation or maybe my
Bishop gets trapped right
um like I can't play Bishop to H5
because simply G4 and my Bishop is
trapped
so I probably do need to take this
Knight in order not to lose some Tempo
but now I've given up the bishop pair
and my opponent still has a light
squared Bishop to defend uh their Castle
so that would be the best but it's maybe
still not the most comfortable or
perhaps the most positionally accurate
so
in this position though my opponent
plays a move
that is also super not super
positionally accurate
um
Queen to D3
unpinning the Knight
but the problem here is this queen is a
little misplaced
I think in retrospect my opponent would
have liked to play Queen to D2 but
didn't want to block in this dark
squared Bishop
and I think my opponent was also nervous
that if I leave this pin for too long
maybe I will be able to have some tricks
against the Knight I don't think that
was really a Justified concern because
the only way I can go after this Knight
quickly would maybe be something like
Knight C6 and then trying to trans pose
it into E4 or sorry E5 or D4 but if my
opponent simply plays something like
Bishop to E3
and I go for this well now this Pawn is
defended this one is covered so and I
can't do anything and you can still play
Queen D2 and get everything you wanted
um without losing any time what happens
in the game though is Queen to D3 I play
Pawn C6
and now Bishop E3 rookie 8 and queen D2
so my opponent gets the same position
except they're actually down a Tempo and
the tempo is just a kind of a fancy word
for time
so notice how in this position it's uh
now Black's turn to move right my
opponent just plays Queen D7 but had my
opponent played this line we said
earlier right instead of playing Queen
to D3 if they had played Bishop to E3
and now let's say I play Everything I
did in the game C6 Queen D2 Rook E8 we
reach an identical position
but in the in this one I get to make a
move and the other one my opponent gets
to make a move so you want to be aware
of you know moving your pieces a lot
um like moving one piece around a lot
and not getting in the way kind of
long-term planning is really helpful for
that
um
question would you ever waste moves to
reverse the battery
um
depends on the situation so I by reverse
the battery I guess you're meaning like
put the queen in front
there are some situations where there
could be like checkmating ideas there
usually I would say it's better if you
try and plan ahead
um
so like I can think of some in like the
C3 Sicilian which is where I'm more
familiar where I will play something
like Bishop C4 drop it back to B3 and
then C2 and then just drop my queen out
to D3 and have like a battery there but
even then even though I'm spending a lot
of time doing it it's like a maneuver
I've planned out and usually I'm able to
get away with it because my opponent is
attacking my Bishop so I I'm trying to
retreat it anyway
so yeah in a super closed position Tempe
isn't as important but generally if
you're just going to switch it unless
you have a really good reason to make
that attack I wouldn't do it
okay so back to our game
and I play Knight to D7 and then this
position I still wasn't fully convinced
I wanted to trade this bishop I was
really hoping my opponent wouldn't play
H3 since they hadn't yet and this is
kind of their big chance to do it if
they want to trap my bishop and force me
to trade it
um now is the time because if you play
like I probably don't want to play
Bishop E6 this is going to get a little
scary if there's ever ideas of D5 yeah
I'm not convinced I'm going to be very
safe here
it might work but it's just a little too
scary
my opponent instead just decides to play
Bishop H6 which is a very common plan
you know lining up the queen and the
bishop but one thing important to note
right is my opponent in the same way
that I would like to trade my light
squared Bishop for theirs and weaken
this Castle my opponent wants to do that
for me
and there's a flaw with both plans mine
is slightly more Justified because I
haven't actually committed to trading
yet but the problem here is neither of
us are in any position to attack the
other's castle if it's on the king side
so my opponents wanting to trade this
bishop
and
weaken my castle
but they they're not really set up to
attack it yet and I kind of exploit that
in a weird way
um probably the best move here is just
to allow a take and I'll take back maybe
I can even take this myself and allow
the queen to come in just because the
threats are it's going to take too long
for white to make a threat
but here I play this move Bishop h8
and decide okay I'm going to give you a
little bit of control of my king just
because I know there's really nothing
you can do about it my opponent plays
Knight to G5 which looks really scary
but there's just no continuation right
there's nothing that can help support
this attack so I actually felt
relatively safe here
at the same time notice that this
position is getting more and more
complex we haven't yet to trade a single
piece and we are making some threats
maybe not major threats of winning
anything yet but at least putting pieces
in positions where threats can occur
later down the line
okay I play Knight to B6
and open up a space for my Bishop to
return home
and uh
because again I still don't want to do I
can't just play something like B5 now my
Bishop is really really super trapped
um because now I don't even have Bishop
E6 for sure D5 cd5 ed5 I can't play
Bishop F5 because of G4
so yeah I have to do something so Knight
B6 to give this a safe home and my
opponent plays this move Bishop F1
which at first looked really really
weird to me like a very mysterious move
in retrospect I think uh it was doing
maybe two things one my opponent really
wants to Queen side Castle because my
opponent really wants to attack my king
right all these pieces are here they
want to get some use out of it
at the same time
so maybe something like Bishop E2 right
is the idea to force a trade and then
allow a queen side Castle but also I
think just simpler
um is controlling C4 my opponent doesn't
want my knight to jump in so I think
that's kind of the purpose of this move
but it does give me some time as this is
a retreating move to play E5 my opponent
has not yet castled so I would love to
break open the center
and my opponent doesn't bite D5
takes takes
and here again there's a lot of moves I
can play to maybe try and simplify you
know just simple developing moves
um but I decide to ramp up the tension
for a few reasons one the same reason I
pulled my Bishop back is because I'm
playing an opponent who is low rated
than me and I am expecting that I'm
going to be better in more complex
situations that didn't exactly pan out I
did win this game but there were some
places where I was making some
questionable moves
so uh in this position though I did find
a really nice idea is I thought okay and
I actually saw this all the way back
with E5 I thought your only real options
are to take and I'm kind of happy
opening this position even if we trade
queens and make it slightly less
complicated because then I have my Rook
on this file and my Bishop is still
controlling the square very well
but after D5 and this exchange I now
have this really big threat of E4
kind of paralyzing White's position
because I'm stopping F3 I'm still
stopping Queen side castles
and you can't even prepare queenside
castles with something like Bishop E2
because of my follow-up
in the game my opponent saw another
threat which is for me to just push this
Pawn to E3 and continue to break things
open
but instead I play or sorry my opponent
plays Queen to E3 to stop that
which is a good idea they don't want me
to press forward unfortunately I have a
nice forcing move here Bishop to F3
attacking the rook and so now I've
decided okay I don't want you to
kingside Castle
um you cannot take this piece right
because if you take now you're revealing
a discovered attack on your king and
queen and this is a pin
if something like this
The Queen Is Lost
so you have to move the rook and you
cannot kingside Castle anymore
and in this position there were two
moves I was really debating between and
maybe I I don't know that I'll have time
to go all the way through this game but
I think this is a very important moment
because I decided to keep up the tension
and complexity when maybe I shouldn't
have in this position like spassky I
should have said I have a winning move I
can be up in material and have it kind
of guaranteed
and that move is Knight to G4
forking the queen and the bishop
at first I was a little nervous about
that move because I thought well if I
play this then what if you just play
Queen F4
I don't have time to take your Bishop
now your Queen's involved in threatening
checkmates so I'm a little nervous what
I missed was I can still take the bishop
anyway because my knight will defend the
Checkmate threat and white really has
nothing else to do
so that would have been the best move
and I did see that I could take this
bishop but I decided I don't want just
to have a nice simple material advantage
I want to increase the complications I
played Knight from B takes D5 and my
idea was there's a lot of tactics
happening here I thought my opponent's
Queen was eventually going to have to
move to D1 or sorry D2 or C1 where I
would just have some very easy wins if
you go to D2 maybe I can play E3 this
looks very strong
if you play Queen C1 then I was looking
at something like Knight take C3 B take
C3 and Knight to G4 hitting this bishop
again but now doing so with a discovered
attack on C3
um yeah like you said in the chat kind
of opening up that Bishop
what I missed was after my opponent
takes
now
Queen B3
uh oh hold on okay wait a minute I think
I'm still fine here but I was very
nervous for a second because now my
knight is pinned and because I let this
bishop linger for so long now there are
some real serious Checkmate threats I
have to be very careful here
I played Queen to A5 check to defend my
knight and call check C3 forced
and um
I've kind of already over complicated
the situation
instead of just taking the simple
Advantage where I could I've given my
opponent a chance to have a nice
a nice attempt and the game basically
continues uh Rook AC 8.
which was fine I'm trying to get a
tactical idea here just breaking through
on C3
Rook C1 defending
um
and there's a lot of complex tactical
ideas I unfortunately don't have time to
get into all of them but my opponent
just kind of tries to end some of the
pressure and unfortunately gives me a
winning idea by opening up the e-file
here
uh the game continued very quickly
Knight before and kind of some forced
checkmating ideas that were very nice
um but actually the last thing I want to
talk about is in this position
with their King so exposed I played this
very very bad move Queen to B6
offering trade of Queens again my
thought was purely I'm ahead in the
material I have one extra pawn and I'm
playing a worse opponent so I should
simplify actually this would have given
my opponent a chance to stay in the game
so keep that advice about complication
simplification I hope this has been
helpful I know I kind of rushed a little
bit at the end but hopefully you can
take something from this to heart and I
look forward to seeing you again soon
please stick around for our Grandmaster
class with Alexander malinski it's going
to be awesome thank you so much
[Music]
thank you
[Music]